well yes
we've changed a lot of our practices
since they've come and
we've changed our six week checks to
eight week baby checks with the
including the vaccine
we ring parents making sure that we've
got a recall system
yeah and get them in for their vaccines
our rate's quite high at the moment
because we're getting them in
today in england it's face mask day
where the regulations
come in how long are we gonna can we
realistically expect to be wearing face
masks for this is gonna be in place for
a year for 18 months for two years
isn't it well it depends sam
the the use of face masks the use of all
the
social distancing measures really does
depend on
our ability collectively to get the
the pandemic right right down and to
keep it down
i'm not going to make a prediction about
when
these various social distancing measures
will uh will come off obviously we've
been able
uh to reduce some of them uh you know we
we've gone we we no longer ask people uh
to stay at home
uh we're trying to get back much closer
to normal
but our ability to dispense with the
the social distancing measures will
depend on our continued ability
to drive down the virus i'm not going to
give you a
a trigger point a trigger moment but
we need to make sure that we've really
really got it under control
we're able to stamp on local outbreaks
and we've really greatly reduced the
the risk of of a second spike so my
message to people
uh over the next few few months is you
know
we've done very well you know the the
virus is under control
in this country to a very large extent
but it is still there and if you look at
what's happening
in other countries there is clearly a
risk
that it could come back again so we do
need
to maintain those social distancing
measures we do need to keep washing our
hands
in shops on public transport in places
where you're going to
be close to people that you don't
normally meet
face coverings are a good idea and that
will
remain the case until we've made a lot
more progress